joe biden is in europe this week to try
to demonstrate unity with european
allies over russia's invasion of ukraine
so we've come to the bundestag the
german parliament here in berlin to
speak to germany's transatlantic
coordinator man called michel link i
want to find out from him
just how united the allies really are
and whether germany is really pulling
its weight michelle let's start with
germany it's been going through this
huge transformation of its foreign and
security policy just in the last few
weeks since the war began
spending suddenly 100 billion extra
euros on defense
how important is this moment for germany
it's an important moment for germany but
it's also a watershed moment for the
european union it's not only germany
spending more it's the european union
for the first time setting up
a program a massive program where the
united
well sorry where the european union is
purchasing weapons it's delivering
weapons
is even having a
ready-made standing force
in the future in the strategic compass
so it's a watershed moment for berlin
but also for our union so some people
around the world used to look at germany
and sort of think of it as a sort of a
big switzerland you know a country that
like to make money and kind of keep its
its hands relatively clean
is that decisively over with now that
time
well that's in within our hands it
should be over it should definitely be
over
and it should have never been happened
in the first place because we cannot be
a large switzerland we are
as germany especially after the second
world war after our experiences we
cannot be neutral we are part of an
alliance we are part of nato we have
part of the european union
we have even a military assistance
clause in the european union treaty not
only in the nato treaty so no to any
neutrality no to any form of in between
of germany we are clearly standing as
ally
among allies and with our allies
now you know ukraine and russia very
well you know eastern europe very well
how worried are you about the situation
right now
extremely so and not only since this
brutal war which is a flagrant violation
of international law but if we can if we
tried to read the signs and the signals
and tried to understand it
already in the last years
since the very prominent and
well in famous speech of president putin
at the munich security conference
in 2007 we should have been knowing that
something is coming
maybe not openly violent and aggressive
but certainly in form of a hybrid
attack
or even war on our western structures
and especially on the unity and
of nato and the european union so it's
not new it became only more visible with
this attack
now
in your career you've had a strong focus
on democratic standards and human rights
when you look at vladimir putin when you
speak about that the speech going back
to 2007 when you look at the development
of him as a leader in russia over these
20 years but particularly in the last
few months
some people see
someone who turned into an authoritarian
but now even going beyond that sort of
almost totalitarian even sort of fascist
overtones in launching the war in the
kind of speeches the words he's been
using recently in public
is that how you see it is that what
we're dealing with here a fascist
dictatorship
i would i wouldn't try to use any
word like fascism it is for sure a
tendency of a increasingly paranoid
dictatorial structure
of its own
but it's clearly
more and more directed to one person
let's not forget he's ruling the country
since 1999.
in the beginning of course he was not as
strong as he is today and even today we
don't know exactly how the division of
labor really works in the kremlin but
one of the things is sure he pulls the
strings he's calling
really
the shots and
he is relying on a small group of people
some of them may know some we don't know
and with this small group he's steering
the country in a more and more
dictatorial way
when i had the privilege to observe the
elections in russia as chief observer in
the last presidential elections we
clearly said
there is an increasing grip on civil
society
and increasing grip also on controlling
the neighbors that could be seen already
four years ago now
nato allies in the region are of course
very anxious about what is happening
how concerned are you that russia and
the vladimir putin is going to start
really testing nato's commitment to
defend those allies
you mentioned just a moment ago that
that he's challenging the west
how concerned are you that this could
could become something where he really
tries to
challenge the very ability of nato to
protect its allies i don't want to
speculate but i'm pretty sure that in
nato we have all the scenarios ready
made in case there is such an attack on
nato territory that's at least what the
planners in nato and the defense
ministers are very good at
so there are the scenarios we don't
speak about that a lot but for sure he
will be testing and he already did
uh in more visible ways in less visible
ways in cyber attack openly and hidden
and i'm pretty sure
with the war in ukraine there will be
attempts of retaliation from the russian
side
also directed to nato and its members
since he considers our sanctions
and the delivery of weapons to ukraine
as
a
extremely unfriendly act so we should be
better prepared for it but cool-blooded
well-prepared and then if necessary act
and react very resolutely now more and
more countries particularly in eastern
europe are saying that in order to try
to stop putin sooner there does need to
be an embargo on importing russian
energy germany so far has been adamant
that it simply cannot do that it would
damage its economy too much do you think
at some point germany is going to have
to consider that and relatively soon to
try to sort of cut off the flow of money
to putin
i think it's very important to explain
that germany does not want to continue
to purchase energy in russia it is
simply not possible to stop it overnight
whether we call it embargo or stopping
the purchase we should do it as soon as
possible i'm very glad the chancellor
put it today in his in his uh
a very important speech to the bundestag
today the first after the watershed
moment he said we should end energy
purchase in russia as soon as possible i
think that's the way forward as soon as
possible it's not possible overnight by
the way we are not the only ones look to
italy look
even to some eastern european countries
we cannot end it overnight but we should
do it
as soon as possible because he
really makes use of this money in order
to run his army it isn't the point that
it might be possible but it would just
be expensive and germany doesn't want to
pay that price it will certainly cost
the price and it already does now
what we try to find is a way
to get
soon rid of any energy purchase from
russia
by first a buying elsewhere second
certainly it will be also more expensive
we will we have to face that lng
terminals cannot be built overnight so
it is a combination of being ready to
pay more but especially also to buy
elsewhere and
you cannot you cannot act in a way that
you
weaken yourself in an extreme way so
that we are not able any more than with
our economic power than to help ukraine
so when we act we should act as fast as
possible we should certainly also pay a
price for it we are ready to do that but
nevertheless it's still not possible
overnight
let's look on the european level again
and and the transatlantic factor in
defense so europe has been saying for a
long time this is a lot more urgency now
that europe has to do more for its own
defense
but aren't we seeing in this crisis just
how crucial the united states is to
european defense
if we imagine where we would be standing
if the united states was not an ally
standing at europe's side at the moment
i would rather not imagine i wouldn't
like to imagine where we would stand as
europeans without
the united states
and canada by the way but especially
united states i'm coming from south by
of germany from baden-wurttemberg
for us south germans it was always
normal to have u.s troops in germany
that was normal that was important that
was part of our life and i think we
didn't really value that contribution of
the united states to european security
and we now have to learn finally that we
have to pay a higher share in this in
sharing of that burden by the way it was
obama in 2014 at the wales summit
who really
made us clearly and in no uncertain
terms
except
the 2 percent clause
it was already way before before we had
president trump
and today it is still not fulfilled so
it's a homework to do we have assumed
that and understood
that duty and that task and we will do
it
now of course there is currently a
president in place in the white house
who looks favorably on europe who's
really tried to rebuild the the
transatlantic alliance um but it's
certainly conceivable
that a donald trump or another donald
trump-like politician could
win the presidency next time in just
over two years
how much is that an a worry for you and
your role but also for germany and
europe when it thinks about these
questions
well first of all it's
a vibrant democracy in the united states
it's a democracy that makes their own
the u.s make their own choice
but we hope that whoever is being
elected
next president but before that we have
the midterms so we are looking way ahead
now but independent of who is president
we want a waterproof relation
where we as
our side from the ocean where we carry
our responsibilities the best investment
to in good relations with the us is that
we do our job and then of course only if
we do our job we can only clearly
address the u.s side in case we don't
like anything we hear from the white
house a good friendship is not about
being quiet and one top one down it's
about everybody doing his job and also
to be open and frank when necessary i
mean with your election observer
background when you look at the
situation in electoral politics in the
united states for instance accusations
that the republic parties the republican
party is trying to
hinder voting rights especially for
minorities does this set off the
election observer alarm bells with you
that the the home of democracy is in big
democratic trouble
well i had the privilege to serve uh for
for many years as the head of the odihr
that is the main electoral watchdog and
the your viewers probably know it
whenever you have international
observers the guys with the osce badge
they are the ones whom i had the
privilege to
to to chair
also in the u.s elections in general
elections and what we are seeing there
also the proposals now on the table
partially they are just modernizing
partially they are okay
but there is a certain limit
what should not be done and that is
always when you make voting more
difficult
but again it's not our job from the
outside to lecture anybody but there are
international standards there are
international standards for good
democratic and fair elections
and they require
every participating state in the osce
including the u.s
to
make voting as easy as possible
fundamental rights should be easy to
execute easy to to use therefore i hope
very much that also in the united states
voting will not be made more complicated
but less complicated
michelle thank you very much for your
time speaking for dw thank you
you